madame monsieur bonsoir accalmie en
Algérie l'état de siège sera levé demain
matin les émeutes auraient fait près de
500 morts
le Belly européenne du pape Jean-Paul II
exhorte les parlementaires de Strasbourg
supplément d'âme
étape mortelle au rallye de San Remo de
pilotes français sur Citroën tués sur le
coup
l'état de siège sera levé demain matin à
6h en Algérie c'est ce qu'annonce à
l'instant un communiqué de la présidente
à Alger la journée a été plus calme
aujourd'hui le discours télévisé du
président Chadi hier soir qui n'a pas
apporté beaucoup de précision sur les
réformes qu'envisagerait le régime a été
appuyé en province par quelques
manifestations de soutien après 7 jours
d'émeutes les bilans en tout cas sont à
la fois contradictoires et provisoire
les autorités font état de 176 morts
avant la fusillade à Bab El Oued hier
après-midi mais selon les journalistes
sur place et les informations
recueillies dans les milieux
hospitaliers il y aurait en fait
quelques 500 morts Jacques Merlino et
François Cornu ont réussi hier
après-midi à filmer la confrontation
sanglante entre intégriste et forces de
l'ordre le reportage et les événements
de la nuit commenté par Bruno le drèff
Alger quartier de Bab El Oued sur le
trottoir le corps d'un homme mort
quelques instants plutôt notre équipe
qui suivait la manifestation a vu un
char ouvrir le feu entendu des tirs
d'armes automatiques notre caméraman
gardera plusieurs minutes l'image de
cette victime dans son objectif avant
que des soldats ne la recouvrent puis ne
la fasse disparaître discrètement armé
omniprésente la manifestation qui
regroupait une majorité d'hommes âgés de
15 à 30 ans se disperse
quelques heures plus tard à la
télévision pas un mot du président
Chadli sur la manifestation et ses
victimes je vais engager des réformes
affirment le chef d'État algérien
a fait ces hommes se sont précipités
dans la rue Taya shadly critique ils
ajoutent shady le peuple est avec toi
ici le président algérien semble avoir
convaincu il faut dire qu'on se trouve
dans son fief pendant 18 ans de la fin
de la guerre d'indépendance à son
élection comme président il a dirigé la
région militaire d'Oran il y ait
toujours très populaire selon aps
l'agent officielle d'information
algérienne de semblables manifestations
ce sont développées spontanément dans
plusieurs autres villes d'Algérie
au même moment les rues d'Alger la
police est venue chercher notre équipe
pour la piloter affirme-t-elle jusqu'à
des manifestations en faveur du
président
des dizaines de kilomètres plus d'une
heure s'écoule rien rien si ce n'est
cette scène le véhicule de police est
arrêté contrôlé inspecté par des
militaires les policiers algériens
doivent même présenter leur papier pour
être autorisé à repartir cette nuit
aucune trace de manifestation pro ou
anti-chedli dans Alger la troupe tient
la rue
Alger aujourd'hui la manifestation
d'hier a fait beaucoup de dégâts on
tente de réparer et face à la caméra
réaction favorable à la déclaration du
président Chadli
nous avons très bien le peuple de la des
problèmes nous avons une direction
politique qui est capable de résoudre
ses problèmes certes il faut des
modifications politiques nous les
attendons
dans la capitale algérienne cet
après-midi on organisait des
distributions de nourriture pour tenter
de calmer les esprits
l'annonce de la levée de l'état de siège
pour demain matin annonce donc qui a été
faite il y a quelques instants à peine
doit être accueilli avec soulagement à
Paris depuis près d'une semaine en effet
l'embarras a été manifeste le
gouvernement Français soucieux des
intérêts franco-algériens et aussi de
l'enjeu régional que représente une
déstabilisation du régime d'Alger le
gouvernement français donc se tait
pierre serra oui je crois qu'il écoutait
les pas nécessaire de rappeler
l'histoire récente et commune de la
France et de l'Algérie pour comprendre
que la relation entre les deux pays sont
difficiles difficiles et surtout
empreinte de susceptibilité
réciproquement français a choisi jusqu'à
présent de se taire a choisi peut-être
de près sans le préférer en tout cas la
prudence au courage aucune voie
officielle ne s'est élevée pour
condamner ou pour dénoncer tout au moins
un régime qui a fait usage de la force
armée pour réprimer dans le sang les
manifestations sans doute des ordonnées
d'une jeunesse qui aspire à plus de
liberté
la prudence comme toujours en Mathias
dogmatique en fait c'est consiste à
préserver l'avenir tout en ménageant les
intérêts respectifs des États en
présence c'est cela qu'on a voulu faire
or l'avenir c'est quoi si vous le dire
le Maghreb qui est en cause aujourd'hui
qui nous intéresse ce sont les marchés
entre Paris âgés pour le pétrole et le
gaz et ce sont les échanges économiques
et surtout des échanges humains il y a
près de 800 000 travailleurs algériens
en France faut pas l'oublier alors on
peut effectivement penser que jusque là
en tout cas Paris a pratiqué une en
l'occurrence une sorte de poétique de
l'autruche en souhaitant que tout
s'arrange pour le plus vite et pour le
vieux Mézières ça sent mort alors est-ce
qu'on a eu raison d'agir ainsi est-ce
qu'on a bien fait si les choses
s'arrangent qu'on viennent de croire nos
pensées avec la levée de l'état de siège
sans doute on aura pour pouvoir oublier
qu'on a rien dit au moins il fallait le
faire mais il est mort demeure dans les
rangs de l'opposition quelques appels au
respect de des droits de l'homme
notamment de la part de pierre meignery
et de Jean-Pierre Bloch qui en appelle à
la Croix Rouge Internationale dans les
rangs des intellectuels plutôt de
l'embarras la Fédération internationale
tranquille aspiraient à la démocratie
qu'ils aspirent au pluralisme et qu'ils
aspiraient à un régime qui leur offre un
avenir et bien je crois que cela ça
n'est pas acceptable et que lorsque l'on
vit dans le pays des droits de l'homme
on n'a pas le droit de se taire des gens
qui massacrent une population de jeunes
qui manifeste simplement pour dire
qu'ils attendent un autre avenir que ce
soit à l'est ou à l'ouest que ce soit au
nord ou au sud on a pas le droit de se
taire et pourquoi avoir attendu cinq ou
six jours pour rompre ce silence nous
n'avons pas attendu nous avons aussitôt
que les informations étaient précises
rendues publiques notre position il y a
de cela 48 heures ce que je peux vous
dire ce soir c'est que maintenant nous
sommes en mesure d'annoncer qu'avec un
certain nombre d'autres associations
nous allons appeler les Français les
Algériens qui vivent en France les
jeunes les intellectuels à manifester
leur condamnation de la répression et
leur solidarité avec la population et la
jeunesse algérienne qui mérite mieux que
aujourd'hui la chape de plomb de la
terreur quelle que soit le combat très
honorable qui a été mené par les gens
qui sont aujourd'hui au pouvoir en
Algérie encore que la plupart d'entre
eux n'étaient pas là au moment de la
lutte de libération nationale cela ne
les autorise pas à tuer aujourd'hui le
peuple algérien
jamais été quand même qu'il y a un
embarras parmi ceux dont vous êtes qui
d'habitude sont tellement pros à
dénoncer justement d'ailleurs les
dénoncer les les entraves au droit de
l'homme dans tous les régimes il y a
certainement un complexe de la part de
la France à l'égard d'un ancien pays
colonisé il y a une certaine culpabilité
une certaine gêne moi je crois que le
rôle de la France n'est effectivement
pas d'essayer d'enfoncer l'Algérie dans
ces malheurs je crois que c'est de
l'aider de l'aider notamment dans sa
recherche du développement économique
mais aussi de ne pas être complaisant
quand aux valeurs démocratiques je crois
que ça serait le plus mauvais des
services à rendre aujourd'hui au peuple
algérien à la nation algérienne que de
passer l'éponge que d'oublier que de ne
rien dire sur les massacres sur les
atteintes aux droits de l'homme qui ont
été commises contre des gens qui au
contraire aspirent à la démocratie je
crois que au moment de fêter le
bicentenaire de la Révolution la voix de
la France la voix des gens qui vivent en
France et qui sont attachés à ces idéaux
doit se faire entendre pour soutenir et
aider tout ce qui revendique aujourd'hui
de vivre dans des pays démocratiques
nous ne faisons pour les Chiliens nous
le faisons pour des tas de peuples dans
le monde pour les noirs qui se battent
en Afrique du Sud nous devons aussi être
aux côtés de la jeunesse algérienne qui
se bat pour ses droits et pour la
démocratie merci
dans la communauté algérienne française
les réactions sont encore prudentes ce
soir et les divisions sans doute
profondes Rémy roche avait passé la
soirée d'hier dans une famille
algérienne à Colombes près de Paris
63 ans dont 31 patients en France depuis
qu'elle a rejoint son mari aujourd'hui
décédé Ada 33 ans né en Algérie mais
français commentaires très dur c'est le
plus politique de la famille Hakim 24
ans il a choisi la nationalité française
après avoir effectué deux ans de service
militaire en Algérie
Yasmina 20 ans né en France l'Algérie
pour elle c'est très loin je suis
contente de voir ça
même s'il y a des morts
on a bien perdu un million et demi pour
avoir l'indépendance
ou pour l'avenir de la jeunesse
ce qu'ils font c'est très bien
pour eux mais nous on voit pas tout ça
parce que vous voulez pas n'est pas à
côté d'eux c'est autre chose pire n'a
pas la même vie on a tout et puis non
pas tout ça des petits malheureux
il y a deux ans j'ai fait mon service
militaire effectivement j'ai vu les
jeunes qui vont qui n'avaient rien du
tout qui avait tous un espoir et puis
bon il voulait tous ils veulent tous
comment dire avoir une vie différente
est-ce que j'espère c'est que bon
l'armée comprendra que bon il y a rien à
faire contre des jeunes d'ailleurs il y
a beaucoup d'Algériens qui se sont levés
déjà j'espère qu'ils vont être de plus
en plus nombreux j'espère qu'ils vont
être de plus en plus nombreux encore et
ils vont l'être ils vont l'être ils sont
touchés de plein fouet
une autre expérience quelle qu'elle soit
sera une expérience et donc sera
bénéfique sera
porteuse quelque part
d'idées nouvelles je pense que ce qu'il
y a de pire c'est que ce régime reste en
place c'est que cet état reste figé tel
qu'il est c'est ce qui peut arriver de
pire l'Algérie comment est-ce que vous
espérez l'Algérie de demain
c'est possible vite
depuis le début de la crise les carouis
sont sans nouvelles de leur famille dans
la région de nasaganem
pour manger dans 10 minutes à peu près
nous diffuserons un extrait du journal
télévisé algérien qui est diffusé en
Algérie en ce moment même et qui fait
état donc de la levée de l'état de siège
pour demain matin à moi après la rentrée
scolaire en France c'est la grogne dans
les lycées malety en enseignant et en
équipement ainsi à Rouen aujourd'hui un
millier de lycéens ont défilé pour
soutenir la grève qui a lieu en ce
moment au lycée Jeanne d'Arc de la ville
le Syndicat national des enseignements
du second degré le SNES lance un
mouvement de grève pour le 20 octobre
prochain c'est à cette date que doit
commencer le débat parlementaire sur le
budget de l'éducation dans certains
lycées comme celui que Chantal Kim
Merlin a découvert au Raincy dans la
région parisienne il est vrai que les
conditions de travail et le climat sont
bien difficiles pour tous
1600 places plus de 2400 élèves ce lycée
est vieux de 30 ans
des classes bondées elle compte jusqu'à
44 élèves la norme nationale est entre
30 et 35 les places sont chères et ce
n'est pas le confort on enseigne ici la
philosophie sur des planches à dessin
nous avons des locaux pour faire
semblant de former les jeunes
c'est de plus en plus décourageant
découragez-y en colère tout le monde
l'est au lycée du Raincy les professeurs
les élèves le personnel administratif le
malaise s'installe avec l'inquiétude de
l'avenir
deux ans tu as des problèmes dans le
lycée même plus et bon il y a pas il y a
pas eu de solution depuis 2 ans quoi et
ça ça nous fout les boules parce que on
a marre et bon c'est maintenant ou
jamais comment ils vont faire l'année
prochaine puisqu'on sait qu'il y aura
300 secondes qui vont venir en plus
comment ils vont faire ce lycée n'a rien
d'exceptionnel la surcharge des
effectifs le malaise des enseignants
c'est le sort de la plupart des grands
établissements français
négociation interrompues ce soir au
ministère de la Santé entre les
conseillers du ministre et les syndicats
d'infirmières une manifestation a eu
lieu aujourd'hui à l'appel de la CGT je
dis les différents syndicats et la
coordination devrait défiler séparément
les négociations devraient reprendre
jeudi soir l'Académie nationale de
médecine dans un communiqué souhaite que
des solutions équitables soient trouvées
dans le conflit des infirmières la CGT
appelle à la recondition de la grève
demain sur la ligne A du RER qui a été
fortement perturbé aujourd'hui une
réunion direction inter syndicale doit
avoir lieu demain midi il faut augmenter
les salaires le secrétaire général de la
CFDT et de montmer la répéter tout à
l'heure au Premier ministre qui levait à
l'Hôtel Matignon Véronic Auger
nous avons dû fermement Premier ministre
que la rencontre de vendredi
du ministre de la Fonction publique avec
les organisations syndicales du secteur
public et nationalisé était une réunion
décisive
car en effet il faut absolument que
cette réunion débouche sur le maintien
du pouvoir d'achat pour l'année en cours
et pour l'année prochaine sinon il y
aura une action qui se développera
monsieur Bérégovoy à vous nous dit qu'il
faut attendre six mois nous nous disons
que c'est maintenant qu'il faut sortir
du bois c'est maintenant avons-nous à
Michel Rocard que le gouvernement doit
prendre en compte les impératifs sociaux
et pas simplement les impératifs
économiques doit faire en sorte que
après le retard accumulé de pouvoir
d'achat dans le secteur public
et les entreprises nationalisées ont
moins ont rétablisse la justice pour
l'année en cours à l'année prochaine la
grève bouchon à la Régie Renault 15000
salariés en chômage technique
aujourd'hui mais le travail a pu
reprendre à l'usine de Sandouville grâce
à des trains arrière venus d'Espagne
changement officiel à la tête de TF1
Patrick Lelay jusqu'ici vice-président
directeur général remplace Francis
Bouygues à la présidence de la chaîne
c'est la fin de la visite en France du
pape Jean-Paul II le souverain pontife a
quitté Strasbourg tout à l'heure pour
rejoindre le Vatican au terme d'un
périple de trois jours dans l'Est de la
France
il a été reconduit à son avion par le
Premier ministre Michel Rocard le temps
fort aujourd'hui était bien sûr le
discours du souverain infantif au
parlementaire européen à Strasbourg un
discours empreint de foi en une Europe
réconfortée et généreuse Jean-Claude
Barigo
le discours de Jean-Paul II au Parlement
européen aurait pu être seulement un
moment important de sa visite en
Alsace-Lorraine et puis il y a eu
l'incident
le pasteur Paisley député d'Irlande du
Nord et ennemi déclaré du catholicisme
chez lui et à l'extérieur avait décidé
de faire un esclandre et il est passé à
l'acte mort à l'Antichrist et au suppo
de Satan a-t-il créé au pape demeuré
imperturbable prise à partie par
plusieurs de ses collègues le
fondamentaliste irlandais fut expulsé
tandis que Jean-Paul II jetait les bases
d'une Europe de tolérance
d'intégrer
sans distinction entre va se faire de la
foi celle de la vie civile
aujourd'hui encore pratiqué
sous d'autres cieux
paraît incompatible avec le génie propre
de l'Europe
telle que la façon n'est les messages
chrétiennes
à part l'incident tonitruant est
programmé du Parlement de Strasbourg le
voyage de Jean-Paul II en
Alsace-Lorraine a revêtu le caractère
équilibré d'une visite pastorale et
diplomatique au cours de laquelle le
pape aura rappelé aux chrétiens de l'Est
de la France et à travers eux aux
croyants du continent européen leur
identité et les exigences de l'Évangile
tels qu'elles sont transmises par
l'Église au parlementaire et à tous les
hommes de bonne volonté a été offerte
par Jean-Paul II une charte de réflexion
absolument ouverte dont beaucoup ont dit
déjà qu'elle serait utile et même
nécessaire lorsqu’en 1992 s'abaisserait
définitivement les frontières
européennes il faut toujours penser
comment donner à cette Europe d'avenir
une âme une arme pas seulement une
technique
les foules immenses ne sont pas venus à
la rencontre du pape dissuader sans
aucun doute par un service de sécurité
omniprésent et un temps en permanence
incertain pourtant les Alsaciens et les
lorins toutes confession religieuse
confondues ont connu semble-t-il un
moment d'unité de ferveur qui
n'oublieront pas de sitôt
histoire un député italien a demandé la
suspension du pasteur irlandais qui
avait traité le pape d'antéchrist de
temps en passant que le Parlement
européen a reçu des autorités françaises
une demande de levée de l'immunité
parlementaire européenne de Jean-Marie
Le Pen à la suite de son triste
kalambour sur un membre du gouvernement
le Parlement se prononcera le mois
prochain
le président du RPCR Jacques Lafleur
rond le silence qu'il observait depuis
quelques jours alors que le référendum
sur la Nouvelle-Calédonie continue
d'embarrasser l'opposition dans un
entretien accordé à nos confrères de RFO
aujourd'hui Jacques Lafleur ne masque
pas les divisions internes du RPR
à ce référendum parce que vous considère
que c'est le prolongement des accords de
Matignon et je voudrais dire aussi
puisque personne de vous ne me l'a
demandé j'ai été désavoué par
Bernard Pons c'est vrai et je considère
que s'il m'a désavoué c'est un échec
personnel il a ressenti ça comme un
échec personnel de m'avoir pas pu faire
aboutir de dialogue mais il était
entouré de telle sorte qu'il avait des
difficultés il aurait eu quoi qu'il
arrive des difficultés à les faire
aboutir en revanche j'ai été soutenu par
le secrétaire général du RPR dans mon
action qui lui est favorable oui j'ai
été soutenu par Jacques Chirac son vert
et qui m'a dit tout le temps où j'étais
en métropole quoi qu'il arrive je te
soutiendrai
pour la première fois depuis son
élection à la présidence en 1981 le
président Mitterrand a exposé lui-même
aujourd'hui la doctrine française en
matière de défense et de désarmement en
s'adressant à l'Institut des hautes
études de défense nationale le chef de
l'État a réaffirmé que la mission de la
France n'est pas d'assurer la protection
des autres pays d'Europe Gérard Beaufils
en matière de défense François
Mitterrand a réaffirmé que l'objectif
est de maintenir notre identité et notre
indépendance et ce à quoi répond la
stratégie autonome de dissuasion
nucléaire alors même si la volonté de la
France est de demeurer solidaire de
l'Alliance atlantique le président de la
République a insisté sur le fait qu'il
ne s'agit pas pour autant d'assurer la
protection des pays d'Europe occidentale
à propos de désarmement le chef des
armées approuve sans réserve l'accord
americano-soviétique qu'il qualifie d'un
des événements majeurs depuis la fin de
la Seconde Guerre mondiale il précise
toutefois que la France ne se privera
d'aucun type d'armes qui serait détenu
par les autres puissances et qu'elle ne
s'associera au désarmement nucléaire
stratégiques que lorsque les arsenaux
des deux super grands auront atteint des
tailles comparable aux nôtres évoquant
la politique de défense commune de
l'Europe François Mitterrand s'est
interrogé est-ce qu'il y a un avion
européen
il y en a un comporte notre pays
d'Europe
il est lourd il le Cher beaucoup plus
cher que le nôtre la France continuera à
fabriquer le Rafale affirmer le
président de la République en déplorant
qu'à cause de la Grande-Bretagne on ne
puisse pas véritablement se mettre
d'accord sur un armement européen
le dispositif épervier mis en place au
chat depuis deux ans va être allégée en
printemps ce soir c'est l'une des
conséquences de la normalisation des
relations entre le Tchad et la Libye
c'est à la fois une revanche et une
volonté sans feuille de lutter contre le
terrorisme que le premier ministre
britannique a voulu afficher aujourd'hui
en retournant à Brighton Brighton ou a
lieu la conférence annuelle du Parti
conservateur la même où il y a quatre
ans un terrible attentat avait failli
lui coûter la vie Philippe Howard
émouvante l'arrivée au Grand Hôtel de
Brighton de Norman tebit et de sa femme
Margaret paralysée à la suite de
l'attentat d'il y a quatre ans monsieur
tebit a été coincé pendant plusieurs
heures dans les décombres provoqués par
l'explosion de la bombe c'était à la
veille de l'ouverture du congrès vers
une heure du matin Madame Thatcher et
ses ministres venait d'échapper de peu à
la mort
la première pensée a été ce matin pour
les cinq victimes de l'attentat dès
l'ouverture une prière spéciale a été
dite par toute l'assemblée le fait que
le premier ministre britannique est tenu
à revenir 4 ans après Abraham dans ce
même hôtel restauré est considéré comme
un défi aux poseur de bon il n'était pas
possible proclame Margaret Thatcher de
tenir le Congrès ailleurs cabraaton pour
la police est un autre défi veillez à la
sécurité des personnalités les plus en
vue du pays rien n'a été laissé au
hasard que ce soit sur terre dans les
airs et même sur mer le thème du congrès
lui-même en dit long conduisons la
Grande-Bretagne dans les années 90 cela
suggère que Madame Thatcher a bien
l'intention d'être toujours là en 1992
après la prochaine élection
remise au pas en Tchécoslovaquie le
gouvernement a démissionné une nouvelle
équipe devrait être mise en place à la
suite d'une réunion plénière du parti au
Chili les partisans du général Pinochet
reprennent confiance Emmanuel Vannier
réunion d'un cabinet d'urgence au Chili
hier soir sous la présidence du général
Pinochet une semaine après le plébiscite
qui a vu la victoire du nom les
élections libres devraient être
organisées en décembre 89 selon de hauts
responsables chilien le général Pinochet
pourrait être candidat à sa propre
succession la Constitution le lieu
interdit mais pour contourner ses
dispositions il suffirait au général
Pinochet de démissionner peu de temps
avant la tenue des élections
retour progressif au calmement
Yougoslavie notamment dans la province
du Monténégro les ouvriers ont repris le
travail après quatre jours de grève les
manifestants n'ont pas obtenu la
démission des autorités locales mais
plusieurs de leurs revendications ont
été satisfaites augmentation du salaire
minimum annulation de la hausse des
loyers meilleure approvisionnement en
pin et en denrées alimentaires seuls les
étudiants continuent leur mouvement de
protestation après le refus des
autorités du Monténégro de reconnaître
les brutalité policière lors des
manifestations
graisse de la fin de cette cure de
depuis une semaine devant le siège de
l'UNESCO à Paris 15 nouveaux grévistes
ont rejoint leur mouvement ce matin il
protestent contre l'utilisation d'armes
chimiques au Kurdistan l'été dernier des
bombardements qui auraient fait
plusieurs milliers de morts et de
blessés et provoquer l'exode de plus de
120 000 personnes les grévistes exigent
de l'ONU je cite une position claire sur
les massacres de l'été dernier et sur
les droits du peuple kurde il réclame en
outre des sanctions contre le
gouvernement irakien responsable des
bombardements
voyons maintenant comment la télévision
algérienne a rendu compte ce soir de la
situation dans le pays pendant plus d'un
quart d'heure le journal télévisé a
diffusé des images de manifestations de
soutien au président Chadli vous voyez
ici les femmes défilées manifestations
donc qui aurait eu lieu spontanément
d'après la présentatrice du journal
télévisé algérien et ce dans tout le
pays il a donc été confirmé au cours de
ce journal que l'état de siège sera levé
demain matin à 6h à Alger et dans les
principales villes d'Algérie
inculpation domicile involontaire pour
ce gardien de la paix il est soupçonné
vous en souvenez d'avoir mortellement
blessé une adolescente de 14 ans samedi
dernier à Noisy-le-Sec
la pluie une sortie de virage sur le
circuit mouillé de français sont morts
aujourd'hui dans la 8e épreuve spéciale
du rallye automobile de San Remo Jean
Mamer
première épreuve spéciale de ce matin le
brouillard et la pluie s'ajoutent aux
difficultés du tracé quand une elle ne
premier sort de la route limité peu
après par la française Carole vergnot
mais la X de Jean-Marc Dubois ne peut
l'éviter et c'est le drame la voiture
écrasée au fond du ravin a tué sur le
coup Jean-Marc Dubois et son copilote
Robert moyen un choc d'une violence
incroyable que rien n'a pu empêcher
malgré ce drame l'épreuve a repris son
cours de nombreux abandons de leaders
comme campunier nous Auriol ont permis
en espagnol carlossen sur ford sierra de
prendre la tête il devance à Lancia
intégrale de Dario Cerato le leader mais
il est déjà à 24 secondes
l'automne à Paris ce n'est pas seulement
la pluie comme aujourd'hui c'est aussi
un festival riche en manifestations
diverses ainsi l'exposition dans un lieu
superbe la chapelle de la Salpêtrière
d'un très grand sculpteur français
Étienne Martin qu'on ne connaît pas
assez Georges Bégot
Etienne Martin aux allures de patriarche
conte aujourd'hui 50 ans de sculptures
des sculptures revenues pour l'occasion
des capitales du monde où elles sont
exposées habituellement il a appelé la
plupart d'entre elles des demeures car
l'homme ne quitte jamais le ventre de sa
mère dit-il ces demeures sont aussi les
maisons imaginaires de l'enfance Étienne
Martin se réjouit de les voir dans la
chapelle de la salle pétrière où elle
contraste avec une architecture d'une
rigoureuse beauté
ce qui est très admirable ici c'est le
lieu et je suis très ému par la
splendeur de ce temple où le sentiment
du sacré est absolument évident
et j'espère que mes choses ne sont pas
trop déplacées dans ce dans ce temple
vous allez 75 ans vous continuez à
sculpter bien sûr
aucune raison de s'arrêter
vous avez dit quelque part j'aimerais
bien être un mage et non un sculpteur
bien sûr mais je ne le suis pas du tout
il n'y a aucun ésotérisme particulier si
ce n'est qu'une chose tout à fait
naturelle
si l'on qu'est-ce qu'il y a de plus
mystérieux que brin d'herbe qui pousse
si l'on médite là-dessus c'est suffisant
on tombe dans un ésotérisme total et on
n'a pas de réponse
les résultats du tiercé à Vincennes le
15 l'as et le 11 il y a photos entre
l'AS et le 11 et je n'ai pas encore les
rapports
vers 23h30 Henri Sannier vous présentera
notre dernier journal demain à 6h45
Télématin la vitesse des quatre vérités
Nicole bénévy porte-parole de la
coordination des infirmières dans un
instant Laurent Cabrol vous parlera du
temps merci d'avoir suivi ce journal à
demain 20h